hey and if instead of taking dad out to
eat you'd rather to stay home and cook
for EM Smith Smith chef Jackson Smith a
chef Jeff Jackson has the perfect steak
recipe for you to try let's check it out
hello everyone I'm chef Jeff from
Smith's okay guys it's father days
coming up and we need to keep dad happy
okay let's get right into it so we're
gonna make a quick little rub out of our
spices here I've got some crushed red
pepper I've got some paprika I've got
some salt sugar is the secret ingredient
guys this actually helps caramelize the
meat garlic powder pepper and then onion
powder it's not seasoning steaks don't
be afraid to over season in fact it's
probably with a piece of meat this big
it's gonna be almost impossible to over
season so go ahead and be generous with
your seasoning we'll go ahead and put
some on the other side as well okay one
important step for this is I had this
steak out for about an hour beforehand
so it could get room temperature that's
just gonna make the cooking process a
little bit easier okay
so the reverse here the idea of this is
to bring it up to temperature before you
put it on the grill and we're gonna do
this in a low oven at 275 oven and make
sure to have a thermometer this is going
to be super essential and getting this
right we're gonna set it for 115 and
that will bring it to a perfect
medium-rare and so that I would stick it
into the middle here all right so let's
go to the oven really quickly let's get
it in there okay of course my
thermometer is gonna be outside when you
grab the one that I have finished okay
guys there you have it I brought this
into a perfect 115 that means it's going
to be medium medium rare probably closer
to rare okay now we need to sear this so
you normally you'd do the searing
process and the very first thing but
this is the searing is going to happen
at the end so our steaks already upper
to temperature and then we're going to
get it in the hot hot pan you could do
this on a grill as well just make sure
it's ripping hot and ready to go and
this is where the sear will happen so
it's going to happen quickly so get it
in
pan don't worry about the smoke because
it's gonna happen don't worry about us
whether that's gonna happen that's
totally normal
this all happens in about 30 to 45
seconds per site so it's really quick it
literally takes just seconds do you see
if we can get this guy flipped over
it's probably about done a little bit
longer on the side and that's okay
but make sure to get a good sear like I
said takes about a minute maybe 45
seconds okay guys so our steak came out
looking super good look at that brown
crust that we got that's what happens
when you do that reverse here and again
it happened so quickly so let's see how
we did let's go go ahead and cut it open
and you guys look at that that is a
perfect rare to medium-rare I'm hungry
and I'm gonna get into this so everybody
happy Father's Day
and thanks for joining me for reverse
seared steaks go ahead and show your
dad's good this year guys we'll see you
next time goodbye
oh right Thank You chef Jeff Will
Smith's food and drug stores have over
thirty locations in the Las Vegas Valley
for more information visit Smith's food
and drug com